[Musique]
on a trouvé tâche est lourde
donc voilà l'autre 5 le char en fait
d'accord et les copains on n'exclut
personne qui tenait excuse moi je dis
pas tous knicks kuimba c'est moi je dis
qu'on exclut les chemins guerre ou cas
je me souviens pas que ça vous dérange
et ça avant avant moi j'aimerais que
l'odeur c'était dû à ses trucs de chaman
la serbe
bah ouais je suis désolé nashwaak
chamanique ya un truc un peu magique tu
vois herbes de provence et ça et quand
tu m'as fait un massage énergétique et
sensorielle tout nu ses toiles cadix et
énergétiques et sensorielle je pensais
que tu voulais qu'on ken mais pas du
tout tu as abusé de ma confiance claude
juste mourir y dit que j'étais chaman
mois juin pas su croire et [ __ ] mais
du temps c'est comme a procédé sous la
pluie on descend c'est penser quoi nous
[Musique]
j'étais bourré